joe ross looking for his first career
win against chicago seven games
six starts a good era basically three
six
nine but oh and three so far
that was the slider in the dirt textbook
block
trace pereira contreras out on the check
swing did not have a very good at-bat
there against joe ross
ortega takes the outside pitch the
opposite way and the lead off
for the cubs center fielder runner on
the move on a 3-2 swing and a miss
and barrera's throw skips and a pretty
good pick up by garcia
to keep it out of center field lifted
off of the glove out in right field
soto and that'll get a run home
wisdom legging it out for third well how
about that swing the bat
kind of a half swing just a block and he
is so strong he hits that one iron
over the head of soto in right field who
misplayed it
but understandably i mean you just don't
anticipate that kind of a swing
generating this kind of a line drive
this is just a little bit of an
emergency hack short and quick
and this ball just continues to carry on
soto kyle hendricks 12 wins
four losses for hendricks he has won 10
straight games he has simply
pitched like an ace
and the strikeout of zimmerman two down
professor really moving the ball around
nicely here
here's a swing of the drive deep left
center field this is way back
and this one is off the glove of half on
the warning track
heading for third around third soto he's
gonna come in to score
and holding it second is yadiel
hernandez showing that opposite field
power
with a boomer to left center that'll be
an rbi double off the glove of happ who
made the effort but that was a tough
play
it's the cubs one in the nationals one
hernandez 10th rbi in the big leagues
this year
well you look at his first inning the
cubs get a run on a ball off soto's club
that he misread this was not a misread
happ had to range back but he certainly
had a catchable opportunity reaching for
it it hit off the thumb of his glove
he almost overreached on it a little bit
there's a knock he's not running as well
as he used to because he had a torn
achilles
but he's important that gets it down to
joe ross who can swing it
great at bat sanchez will make the turn
and
go back to second two one for victor
robles here
nine pitch single for joe ross
up the middle both got some spin on it
and it gets away from the second baseman
el contra
you can kind of see that thing with some
action on it
and the bases are loaded with two outs
for
juan soto soto
shifted onto the grass was alcantara
perfect
position and they will leave them loaded
ross delivers this one is swung on and
missed a slider to the outside and joe
ross
has strikeout number three couldn't get
it down there
joe ross slider and change up pretty
effective to the lefty
strikeout number four david bode leads
off the inning lines went down the left
field line that's a fair ball skipping
into the corner bouncing off the wall
chasing it down as hernandez lead off
double david bodie
cubs have a man at second with nobody
else cody gets a third base with just
the one out now al contra will have a
chance to drive in that run
let's send that one the opposite way and
that's a base hit
and bodhi will lay it out and get
chicago the 2-1 lead rbi
for sergio alcantra and on the throw
he'll head to second well good work
there get him over get him in
hayward hits the ground ball to the
right side of contra
the rbi base hit a little flare a little
floater in the shallow left body has to
wait wait wait to see if that ball is
going to be caught
production from the bottom of the order
and here's andrew romine
andrew that's a fair ball
around third and he will coast home
extras
for romaine he's two for two tonight
and it's a two-run lead well how sweet
does this feel for andrew romain 35
years old spending all year down in the
minor leagues finally getting this
opportunity
there's the outfield double hernandez
is playing it out there and left would
not have mattered run would have scored
and romaine would have ended up on
second base anyway
well struck center field back it goes
and it's gone
rafael ortega
two-run shot home run number three on
the season for
ortega and the cubs breaking out in a
big way here that's a third extra base
hit fourth hit in the inning
a couple of doubles a single and now
this long one from
ortega
that's a fair ball terrific snag by
wisdom the race
to the base and he wins it wow heck of a
play by patrick wisdom stevenson can
really scoot and it was an eyelash call
at first base
for malachi and moore the o2
check swing did he go around yeah he did
strike three
and hendricks gets out of the jam
midfield hit last time
that guy just hits the ball hard
everywhere
we have a man down wisdom rounds the bag
and luis garcia
a collision there on a ball right in
between
garcia and sanchez first run of the game
scored with two outs the ortega home run
also
coming with two outs
base it jason hayward
wisdom will come around to score
then hayward breaks through to drive one
in
this time he does find a hole in that
infield gets on top of that ball beats
it into the ground but
with enough pace to get it through the
infield and pick up rbi number 20 on the
season
and now the one-two paul strike three
zipton on the outside corner roble's
caught looking one two three frame
for kyle hendricks he's just rolling
along brothers works for the stretch all
of the time
and the pitch swung on line to the gap
in right center and down for a base hit
and it will go all the way to the fence
in right center soto on his way to
second
centerfielder ortega plays the caramel
off the wall and gets it in it's a
lead-off double for juan soto
now hit in five straight games first hit
of this night
that's a base hit soto scores easily
zimmerman stops at second the nats are
back on the board
and just like that the tying one will be
in the on deck circle in a 6-2 game
third pitcher of the night is cody hoyer
40 games this year with the white sox
traded a couple of days ago
in the craig kimble deal a double and a
walk
already in the inning and a run in for
washington
the 2-1 fastball bouncing ball to third
coming home with it as bodhi they get
one
and that's all but they get the lead man
high in the air left center happen
ortega
center fielder will take charge one
runner will move up
as bell scores and now it's six to three
and ortega made the good throw to keep
garcia at second line softly to short
gloved on one hop by romine over the
first in time to end the enemy
excellent job by cody hoyer in his cubs
debut
bottom of the ninth inning one away a
man at first in the 2-2
bouncing ball to short shovel to second
for one the throw to first double play
cubs win the ball game
romine to alcontra to wisdom 6-4-3
twin killing this series is tied at one
win apiece
kyle ryan gets the save kyle hendricks
gets the win
and the cubs beat the nationals 6-3